[Music]  things seem to be heating up between  Priyanka Chopra and Nick Jonas check out  the rumored couple looking summer chic  for a dinner date at Park Avenue summer  in New York City Tuesday night the  quantico actress sported a powder blue  satin dress with a white blazer draped  over her shoulders while 25 year old  Nick wore a sporty black shirt white  pants and a trendy fanny pack  in recent weeks Priyanka and Nick have  been spending lots of quality time  together  I need someone though Nick did not  attend the Royal Wedding with Priyanka  in May the jealous singer did bring the  35 year old actress as his plus-one to  his cousin's wedding in New Jersey over  the weekend and the day before the  nuptials the pair was photographed for  the first time together since news of  their rumored romance broke walking  through JFK Airport  [Music]